in update 28 we showed you the challenge
we have with our current toilet the
toilet is getting quite crowded
especially during the rush hours this
means that we would like a new toilet
and currently we are dropping every time
a bucket of poo into this hole we don't
really know what to do with it so in
this video we are gonna build another
toilet and find a way to solve the poop
problem welcome to another pressure cam
update
so this is our current toilet it's a
cool toilet but maybe it's too high for
some people
the space is quite tight
everything is in the middle
this space is quite dark we use this
lamp we don't have natural light so
without it we would be like this
the wood is in contact with the soil so
it rods faster
we cannot clean our hands
so with only one toilet we don't have
enough for the amount of people that we
are in Camp
and more people means more poop so we
would like to rethink how we manage it
because right now we just throw it in a
hole and cover it and we would like to
find a good solution
we need to build a new toilet
make a new design improved and also make
a new poop system let me show you how it
will look like
new toilet design
let me show you the improvements we have
design a deck
that will go over some Stones some
concrete Stones so that the wood is not
in touch with the ground and it doesn't
root so next thing we have added is a
sink that way we can clean our hands and
clean our teeth and we can do it in a
dry space because we have added this
roof here
that covers all this area
in the back of the toilet we have added
a window so that we have natural light
next here are the doors
to take out and put in the pool basket
because we will continue to use those
bucket Zips in in previous videos
and this box is just to stir some
Sawdust because right now we don't have
as much dirt as we would like to and
that way the storage is next to the
toilet so that also the period back is
integrated yeah that's quite it now that
you guys know how it's going to be let's
build it no
let's go
we decided to do it here it's next to
the current toilet and next to the pool
hall
and for that to be able to start we will
have to clear the space
and make some new paths and for that I
will have the help of Ali Andrew
[Music]
thank you
now that we have a clear space I'm gonna
level a frame so that we can fill it up
with dirt and start with a leather
surface
foreign
[Music]
smooth
so as you can see we are trying to
flatten this area
with this beam but it's not working so
Jaime just invented
a new instrument is it working
everything is working
let's see if it's levels
whoa and let's try
so good
the area is already cleared the ground
is ready for now we can get some stumps
and go get the wood
so we can start building our toilet
okay so we went to the local Sawmill and
we bought a few beans and a few planks
to make the deck
[Music]
good
all right
to prevent the beams to touch the ground
we decided to use some concrete blocks
that we already had
foreign
s in their place we have also sanded and
oil the beams and the plants
so now we just have to build everything
hello
we went again to The Sawmill to get some
planks for the day
with all the blanks in base camp I
sanded them
and they oiled all the planks to build
the deck
to put the whole structure together I
only use screws and I only used 80 100
and 120 millimeter screws
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
done one of the problems we want to try
to shop in the new toilet is the height
of the seat right now in the current one
it's too high
and that's the fact that we're using
standardized bucket and we want to keep
using those we've decided to come here
to the back
where the bucket will be and cut
a space
so that we can go lower with the seat
let's start cutting some wood
[Music]
okay base is done so we went again to
The Sawmill
we ordered everything at the same time
but the saw was broken so I think we
went like four or five times to get all
the wood and this time really is the
last time that we went to The Sawmill
and we got everything we need
[Music]
foreign so now that I have all the
materials here I can start preparing
everything for building it
[Music]
got the beams cut the angles for the
frame preparing the siding sanding
everything and router out the edges
[Music]
after a day prepping the wound I got
some extra help because it was a lot of
work
[Music]
now that every piece is sanded they can
be able to protect the wood but it's too
hot let's find another place
[Music]
can I help you yes please
at this point we have all those beams
sanded and oiled and we've seen that
when you oil
with a cloth the process is longer takes
much longer but you use less oil so now
we can start assembling Jaime
let's go
thank you
[Music]
so with opens it's got it to size sanded
and oiled I pre-assembled the walls
thank you
[Music]
and with everything pre-assembled I
screwed everything together and fixed it
to the deck
foreign
[Music]
we also pre-assembled the roof before
putting it in place
[Applause]
put it on the back and then just slide
it to the floor that's I think
[Applause]
I'm the wrong person bro
that side
this one
yeah one second I can't reach
I guess yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm happy with the progress yes
it's looking nice
in life
is not treating me but the last few
months
so yeah I could say that
why not
England will you be happy with a new
toilet
uh yes
I will be happy when I don't have to
wait to take
that sounds really good
[Music]
video maker advice don't put a GoPro
enemy mother to make a time lapse
[Music]
we also decided to install a little
window for the toilet to have a bit of
natural light and ventilation we already
had those windows in base camp we
recovered them from an old house that
was demolished so we can use this one
you don't see from outside to the inside
that's cool
before starting with the siding I'm
gonna install a few trims that I made
with leftover boards we're gonna use
overlapped life at cedar planks and I
don't really like to see the sides of
the planks it's gonna work as a cover of
the sides
all right
[Music]
so it's without glue but
looking better than expected really
I've got everything with a drag saw
without the table saw and no glue but
it's still looking
okay
I'm happy with it
I think we have wood enough but still
after cutting all the planks to size I
started putting anything together
[Music]
so Jaime has started with the setting do
you guys want to check out how is it
looking like
hello Jaime
[Music]
cool
that's how spontaneous
what are you doing
I'm measuring this offcut I have a
corner here that I have to cut off the
board
and yeah I'm marking way after that okay
but before Jaime finishes the toilet we
need to get some things shopping
[Music]
we need some things for the day yet
so what we are doing now is we are
headed to different second-hand shops so
to see what they find
your camera
what do you think
okay
do you think would look good
how's it going Mariana
we are different we are looking lots of
things
[Music]
this fits
[Applause]
what do you think
a bit small but I don't know maybe it's
the best size this is a standard
I wanted the big ones but I think this
ones are easier to find
[Applause]
how many are we taking seven I think
we are heading back to go
after an intense day of surgery called
weeks so we'll see
we didn't find a lot of stuff
but we found some basic things that we
need
we found the pallets as you can see
found this basket for the period basket
this little piece that we will use as a
sink
and we found some cool hinges
which they look new for the toilet door
bottle container that we had here in the
white tent and we will we will reuse it
let's finish it
with the leftover wood that we got I
made a door and used the hinges that we
got from the Second Hand Shop
[Music]
door done let's continue with the siding
okay
[Music]
I'm gonna do the plywood things for the
toilet
I have my fancy drawings
[Music]
foreign
no I'm screwing what Emily did that
doesn't look that bad actually never
mind
yes done
[Music]
okay I got the box ready here goes the
bucket here goes the period basket
here goes the sawdust I'm gonna continue
with the
with the other box
this is that one
is next
[Music]
okay I'm meta screw holes for the screws
but they're on the wrong side they
should be here should be on this side
it's a pointed but not surprised
we are gonna build it at some point uh
we need to make a hole here
to the ball
why
uh because the sawdust is storage
outside so we want to access it from the
inside also Valley
so many options uh this one this one I
think okay
[Music]
hmm
very comfortable yes
so this is the Box the toilet box that
Emily is working on we still have to
connect this part
here to make the full connection with
the Box on the outside this hole here is
where the piece is missing
[Music]
uh we need to hammer it a little bit
good now
[Music]
we have this door so now the problem is
they they doesn't get closed
what is this thing
they have similar here very nice
and it's red
[Music]
yeah
yeah you can go back to sleep I mean
this box this cool box and we are going
to use it sister suggest
second precious plastic toilet seat
when we build this to it we use this one
white and black version
this year we are going for this
completion of colors pretty cool
[Applause]
so one for the wood chip
and one for the previous
[Music]
thank you
there we have it
a small mushroom handle made out of
mimosa with a makeshift blade so
to give you an overview here we have
base camp our current toilet is here and
the utility is being built right here
everything is going good there but
making a toilet is just one part we also
need to process all the poop that goes
in there and currently everything goes
here we just throw it in there with some
soil on top not a very good solution
mainly because it smells and doesn't
compost so we asked our online community
for some help and input and what would
be a good way we got some nice
suggestions and are going to be the
structure for it using gold palettes the
plan is to turn everything that goes in
there into compost but this process will
take a few months so we need quite some
space to store it so first step make
some space
[Music]
okay so today we're going to be
improving the access towards our poop
hole system which is over there so
currently there are three parts that we
are using however none of them have
steps so it's a little bit of a slippery
Hazard so the three of us are going to
be working on installing some steps
right here and hopefully we can prevent
a show from happening
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
have the steps build now we have an easy
access
to this new area we also have
cleared this space where we're going to
start the hay on the buckets and where
it's time now to start assembling the
beans here in this nice clear area
[Music]
it's 32 pallets most of them we got for
free and well we can start assembling
them we're going to build a 12 boxes
like 12 bins for the compost and let's
see how it goes
yes
[Music]
now we need to get quite an amount of
straw for the poop system luckily a
neighbor comes every year to cut the
grass of our Fields he makes travels and
uses them to feed his animals so we
asked him to leave some for us to use
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
so now our setup is ready to be tested
let's see how it works
okay let's film some the first step
is to take the bucket away from the foot
of pork
and put it in its place
winner heavy day so we put it in here
with the rest of the bucket bus first we
have to set up the composting bin
wow
okay first we have to make like a nice
thick layer of hair in the bottom to as
a biological spawn as they call it to
all of the extra liquid so first
we just put it a good amount
of hay at the bottom around 40 to 50
centimeters at least so now that it's
fully covered and there's enough
uh
hate to absorb everything
we have the but I'm ready we have to
work on the sides and for that we're
going to use
what they call
hay chips it's like this like a slice of
the hay of the Bale straight like this
and we put it on the sides
yummy
poo Palace
but what does that mean
after this first try we realized that we
need some Lids to keep the buckets
closed and avoid the smell
we're just gonna make very simple wooden
Lids to keep the smelling and animals
out
[Music]
so we have our first lid it is held
together by two supports on the bottom
which fit into
prevent it from sliding and on the top
we have a chamfered handle
so we have 11 more of these to make
we're gonna get the team involved and
knock them out
[Music]
okay so at this point we've finished all
12 of the lids they've been sanded
they've been oiled and now they're ready
to be taken to their forever home
let's see if they fit
they fit
second week into the new poop system and
we only have four buckets
[Applause]
we open up what we have covered last
week we put the new poop in it connects
the last week's poop and then we will
cover it again of course
oh there it is
you're scared yes
very much
it doesn't look bad though yeah
last one
thank you
we had the beat going
what Julie I'm seeing something moving
yeah that happens last time we also saw
now we pour the pour the poop in and we
cover it again
cover the poop
system is running we can go back to the
building of the toilet
so today I'm going to be working on the
last missing part of the toilet we went
to little sink area last week I saw this
nice piece of uh red cedar in The
Sawmill so my idea is to cut a straight
line in the back which is going to be
the back of the sink
leaf
the front Live Edge and then try and cut
to 45 degree angles here
and here and fold the two pieces
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
I ran into a bit of a problem here
my blade isn't deep enough
so this is the farthest goes
so I think I'm going to have to flip the
piece
just finished the cuts
pretty happy with it I love the book
match we have right now here from the
grain so cool
[Music]
I think it looks pretty cool
there you come yes
what second toilet
it's good but let's check it with a big
guy
it works
[Music]
okay so this is the light we have been
using in our toilet
and inside it there are four LED on the
front and the back and for the back one
we never use it so we took it out and
put it in the old light
we got it from the yellow bin so let's
connect
[Music]
during the building of the toilet I take
the cable for the light connections
foreign
[Music]
to finish everything we feel they come
with water
[Applause]
fill the service box
nice to see that everything works
how many do you think we can put three
of those blue buckets here four is just
gonna be too much but three of those
yeah which already helps a lot insult an
awesome toilet paper holder made out of
mimo some
foreign
the area with some dirt and wood chips
so this is the inside of the toilet
looking good a lot of space
here we have light that Kevin did and
here is the window for some natural
light and some ventilation precious
plastic seat
cool
here we have a compartment for
toilet paper storage and period basket
and here we have storage for service we
also have the with us always here we
store all the sawdust
and this box is connected through a hole
in the hole that goes to the solar
storage in the inside part of the toilet
and the sink
it's a simple system we just have this
water container
which we can get some water from and
when we're finished cleaning our hands
we can just get the water throw it or we
can also water the plant
the back door
if we open it the space for the bucket
for the poop and we added some ribs so
that is easier to fit and here we can
store also some more toilet paper but
the roof is not finished we want to try
our experimental roof made with cans
here's a sample Kevin made
looks awesome
but for that we need more cans 500 into
them so we will show it in another
update subscribe to follow we are also
publishing the drawings of this toilet
in the research model so you can
replicate it or improve it and this is
our new poop area let's see how it goes
in the long run
so the toilet is done I am we are very
happy with the result and that's it for
this video next video is gonna be about
getting some goats I'm joking it's gonna
be about kitchen so if you'd like to see
the video now you can support us in
patreon and if not see you next week bye
thank you foreign